radical republican congresswoman lauren  bobert thinking she's making a really  great point about guns says listen after  9 11 we didn't ban planes when 9 11  happened we didn't ban planes we secured  the cockpit  so why would we ban guns after a mass  shooting and this is so many levels of  stupid first of all of course  the point of planes  is a little bit different than the point  of guns  normally  you don't have the same risks with  widespread  plane travel that you do with widespread  gun ownership but of course more  importantly after 9 11  we did ban all sorts of different things  on planes including box cutters which  were used by the terrorists on 9 11. we  established tsa  we started no-fly lists we did so many  things after 9 11. it couldn't possibly  be a worse example